Welcome students to the
Pharmacology
of Antibiotics.
This lecture is on
the folate synthesis
inhibitors, Dr.
Goldstein speaking.
The typical
learning objectives,
mechanisms,
mechanisms, mechanisms.
Here are links if
you prefer to learn
by reading review
books or text books,
you don't have to
use the video if
you don't want to,
it's not required.
what you need to know
and understand. So here
are key points no
matter what resource you
use for your new
learning. This is what
you're going to need to
know for this course.
And that brings us to
the folate synthesis
inhibitors beginning
of the lecture.
These sulfonamides are
structurally related
to this natural product,
paraamino benzoic
acid, which is a
precursor to folic acid.
You can see the
similarities
here, I believe,
with Paba.
Here is the sulfonamide,
which gives this
class of drugs its
name, the sulfonamides.
This structure is a
sulfone for dapsone.
I will not be
covering this drug in
this lecture.
You are likely to
see it in a future
lecture sometime,
and the properties
are generally pretty
close to the same
as the sulfonamides,
but the spectrum
of action is
different. That's all
I'll say about that.
Now trimethoprim is
not asulfonamide. It's
not structurally related
to para-aminobenzoic
acid. It is an analog
of dihydrofolate,
which is the second,
approximately
second, step in the
folate synthesis pathway.
Folic acid folates,
activated folate, is
essential for the
synthesis of purines, DNA,
RNA, and proteins at
the end of the line.
Sulfonamides
and trimethoprim
are not used alone.
They are bacteriostatic.
There is a
great deal of
resistance against them.
They are generally
used together
in fixed
combination, so all
together in one
pill or one IV bag.
therefore we I will
be talking about
them together for
the most part.
Pyramethamine
is another
dihydrofolate reductase
inhibitor against
certain protozoa that
is used together
with the sulfonamide.
You should be aware
of this drug too.
Sulfonamides have
been around a long
long time. The first
one, sulfanilamide,
was marketed in
1935, and the
way the categorization
scheme was much
less sophisticated
than it is now.
They are divided
into agents that are
absorbed and excreted
rapidly, agents that
are poorly absorbed
when administered
******, and are
active in the bowel
lumen. Actually, there's
only one of them.
Agents that are
rapidly absorbed but
excreted slowly,
so they'd be long
-acting, and then
the topical agents.
This is a
generalization, I mean I
should say a big
overview. I put it
this way, so to
encourage you to
kind of get the
scheme, the pattern,
the general class
effects before you learn
about the individual
drugs, the individual
drug names. I have
bolded and put stars on
the drug names that you
need to know because
they are either in
broad use or they are
essential for treatment
of certain infections
or they are highly
relevant on board exams.
all of these in
fact might be highly
relevant on a board
exam the bolded drugs
are all rapidly absorbed
except these two
which are just topical
you do need to know
the topicals and here
is trimethoprim the
non sulfonamide and
here is the combination
of sulfamethoxazole
and trimethoprim. So
it is called TMP-SMX
to use the letters.
Variable protein binding,
it depends on the
drug. They distribute
in body tissues and
fluids, so they get to
where they're going.
We see hepatic
metabolism,
CYP2C9, and also
anacetylation,
N-acetyltransferase
type 2.
trimethoprim we have our
CYP2C9 again
and also 3A4.
The excretion
is unchanged
through the kidney.
Same with trimethoprim.
Therefore as you could
expect because these
drugs are in high
concentrations in urine,
you might say to
yourself, gee, I wonder
if they're really
good for urinary tract
infections, which, by
the way, are caused
mainly by E. coli and
other gram negatives.
And the answer is yes.
A particular adverse
effect that can occur
because of
sulfonamide's structural
propensities is that
they tend to participate
precipitate in acidic
urine particularly the
older ones but it
includes sulfamethoxazole
which is widely used
here it is and when
the drug precipitates
It forms crystals,
and those crystals can
cause crystal urea.
A couple of half-life
things I want
to point out.
Trimethoprim has a
half-life of, say, 10
hours, and
sulfamethoxazole has a half
-life of about 11 hours.
So it makes sense
that these two would
be put together,
that sulfamethoxazole
in particular,
because of its
similar half-life.
Anything else?
That's pretty much it.
Metabolism.
So, sulfonamides
have this particular
metabolic pathway
that involves an
acetyltransferase
type 2, which is
associated with
polymorphisms that
lead to rapid and
slow acetylators.
If we have a patient
who is a slow
acetylator, that's
going to slow
down this part
of the pathway,
which could shunt
drug towards
this part of the pathway.
Over here,
these oxidative
metabolites
are detoxified
by glutathione.
And if the patient
has reduced levels of
glutathione, that's
going to push towards
the toxic metabolites. So
increased concentrations
of toxic metabolites
in patients who
are poor metabolizers
and thinking about
the really poor
metabolizers or have low
glutathione levels as
occurs in high stress
disease situations
such as AIDS patients.
these toxic metabolites
can cause direct
cytotoxicity to the
skin causing rash to the
liver and certain other
organs so this would
be a hypersensitivity
reaction due to
direct toxicity and
an immune-related
hypersensitivity due to
the immune system attacking
haptans that form from
these metabolites.
And then the immune
system attacks it.
So these metabolites
that cause direct
toxicity are reactive
oxygen species.
See how that all works?
together
mechanism.
Looking at the
figure on the right
-hand side, we have
our sulfonamides
and sulfone that
act at this first
step at dihydroteroate
synthase.
Here's the name
right here.
blocking that step.
And we have our
dihydrofolate reductase
inhibitors acting
at this step.
So it's a one-two
punch on that folate
pathway, folate
synthesis pathway.
So what about
selectivity?
well mammals like
us human beings do
not synthesize folate
we don't synthesize
it from a precursor
paba we get it
from our diet so we
don't we're we're
not involved with
that step at all we
don't have dihydroteroate
synthase we do
have dihydrofolate
reductase However,
the trimethoprim and
the pyrimethamine
have much, much,
much, much greater
affinity for the
bacterial, or in the case
of pyrimethamine,
the protozoal
dihydrofolate reductase.
So at the typical
therapeutic levels,
the human dihydrofolate
reductase will
not be inhibited.
Spectrum of activity.
Aerobic, gram
-positive and gram
-negative. And this
gram-positive even
includes community
-acquired MRSA.
This is, of course, if
there's no resistance.
And then Pneumocystis
urovici is a yeast
infection that occurs
in people with a
suppressed immune system
like AIDS patients.
And then some protozoa
I mentioned before
will see toxoplasmosis
is a good example.
Well, acquired resistance,
plasmid transfer
or random mutation
under selection pressure
will decrease permeability
to the drug so
the drug does not get
into the organism or it
gets pumped out,
increasing the production
of para-aminobenzoic
acid so it actually
outcompetes the drug at
dihydroteroate synthase,
and modification of
the enzyme targets.
These are organisms
that cause common
infections, and
don't you know, their
Their susceptibility
is really low now.
The drugs are still
effective against
certain uncomplicated
urinary tract
infections as long as
the E. coli, Klebsiella
that cause it are
still susceptible.
There is considerable
intrinsic resistance.
sometimes it's easier
just remember things
like that the
intrinsic rather than
remembering what it's
effective against
so anaerobes so good
only against aerobes
enterococci so
we've seen that over
and over pseudomonas
aeruginosa seen that
over and over it's
not effective against
spirochetes, so
it's not going to be
good against Lyme
disease or ********.
Mycoplasma, that causes
community-acquired
pneumonia. It
doesn't affect that.
Mycobacterium
tuberculosis
and other mycobacteriums.
And an interesting feature
is that sulfonamides
stimulate the
growth of rickettsia
rickettsia rickettsii
causes Rocky Mountain
spotted fever which can
be deadly we know that
doxycycline is first
line for that drug but
we don't want to make
a mistake and say
okay well we can
give so trimethoprim
sulfamethoxazole certainly
not absolutely not So,
speaking of
therapeutic uses,
the sulfamethoxazole
and trimethoprim
are wide use
against all of those
susceptible bacteria
mentioned previously.
Sulfadiazine and
pyrimethamine are for
toxoplasmosis, and
it is first line.
Remember, pyrimethamine
is a potent
dihydrofolate reductase
inhibitor, so that's
going to have some
effect, potentially, on
human levels of active
folate. So this drug
called Leucovorin is
recommended in addition
just to prevent
megaloblastic anemia.
Sulfidoxine with
pyrimethamine is malaria.
However, there is so
much resistance to this
that it's not used
for treatment anymore.
And sulfasalazine
will meet
this in a future lecture.
or two future lectures,
this is one that's
not well absorbed,
a little bit, but
not well absorbed.
So it acts in the gut
for inflammatory bowel
disease, and whatever
little bit of the
sulfa component that's
absorbed is effective
for the treatment of
rheumatoid arthritis.
The mechanism on that
is just not clear.
Topical,
sulfacetamide sodium
for eye infection.
It's also
available for
dermatologic use.
Silver sulfadiazine,
I put a star on.
This is for burns.
Silver is slowly
released and
it's toxic to the
bacteria. So, the
silver is an
active component.
Maffinide or
maffinide acetate is
also for burns and
it's effective.
However, it's readily
absorbed from the
burn area compared to
silver sulfadiazine,
which is not absorbed
through the skin.
Now, for small burn
areas, that's not
going to be a
problem. But for large
burn areas, if
it's used, it can
actually cause metabolic
acidosis because
it's a carbonic
anhydrase inhibitor.
Plus, it can
cause intense
pain when it's applied.
Adverse effects. I
mentioned before skin
reactions, and they
can be minor or severe.
But minor skin reactions
are very uncomfortable
for a patient and
very disturbing.
They can cause Stevens
-Johnson syndrome,
exfoliative dermatitis,
photosensitivity.
This is Stevens
-Johnson syndrome here.
Toxic epidermal
necrolysis.
They can cause
fever. That's a
sign of systemic
involvement.
Hepatitis, that's the
direct damage
to the liver.
Hematopoietic disturbances,
granulocytopenia,
aplastic anemia,
thrombocytopenia,
leukopenia. Again, by
damage to the blood cells.
They're rare, but
potentially fatal.
Important, important.
If a patient develops
a rash, the drug
should be removed
immediately, and the
patient should be told
to stop taking the
drug if a rash appears
and to call the
doctor, or if it's
severe, to go to the
emergency department.
Patients with glucose 6
-phosphate dehydrogenase
deficiency are at
risk for hemolytic
anemia with oxidative
drugs or oxidative
metabolites due to
reactive oxygen species.
Bone marrow suppression,
I mentioned that before.
Crystaluria, I mentioned.
Newborns. This
crinicteris
is a type of
encephalopathy.
Sulfonamides
displace bilirubin,
unconjugated bilirubin,
from albumin binding
sites. That
leads to elevated
levels of unconjugated
bilirubin, which
then passes through
the leaky blood
-brain barrier and
deposits in the CNS.
And that causes
the encephalopathy.
So newborn infants,
and really, it's
extended to less
than one month.
Pregnancy, the same
thing. Late pregnancy.
Plus, all
antibiotics, they can
cause C. difficile
infection.
This is a scheme that
I've presented before.
showing the mechanism
of G6PD deficiency
causing increased
glutathione,
sorry, decreased
glutathione reductase
and therefore
decreased glutathione
detoxifying
capabilities. Also,
NADPH is necessary
for conversion of
methemoglobin, which
doesn't carry oxygen,
to our oxygen
-carrying hemoglobin.
So increased levels
of methemoglobin
or methemoglobinemia
due to a
reduction in NADPH
due to glucose 6
-phosphate dehydrogenase
deficiency will
cause both of these
adverse effects.
and a picture of crystal
urea patient with
all sulfonamide crystals
that precipitated
in the urine i want
to point out here
this drug interaction
you see i put a star
on methenamine this
is an important drug
interaction methenamine
is something called
a urinary antiseptic
it is not a
sulfonamide. It is not
like trimesoprim. It's an
antiseptic. It's used
for prophylaxis of
urinary tract infections.
Methanamine turns
into formaldehyde
and ammonia in acidic
urine, And this
combination with a
sulfonamide can cause
precipitation and crystal
urea. I would like
you to remember this.
Here's a picture of
the one on the right is
a child who had
cronicteris as a newborn.
And the drawing on
the left, you can see
some signs of cronicteris
in this child.
elevated levels of
bilirubin deposit
in the skin and
that's how it
causes the yellowing
of the skin.
Now trimethoprim.
It's oral, well
-absorbed, widely
distributed in fluids
and tissues just
like we saw with
the sulfonamide,
sulfamethoxazone.
There's some hepatic
metabolism excreted
in the urine
as unchanged drug
and a half-life
of in the neighborhood
of 10 hours
if you want to
remember it that way.
So it's given
twice a day.
I'm sure you recognize
the similarity
in these pharmacokinetic
properties with
sulfamethoxazoles.
Mechanism of action
inhibits bacterial
dihydrofolate
reductase and therefore
interrupts the folate
synthesis pathway.
The monotherapy,
which is hardly ever
used, is for acute
uncomplicated urinary
infection if the
organism is still
susceptible and for
prophylaxis of UTI. You
might see it that
way more frequently.
It can cause
megaloblastic anemia,
which is decreased
folate levels,
and that leads
to anemia, and we
see the blood cell
adverse effects.
It's related to low
folate levels. Drug
can also cause
hyperkalemia, And that
should be watched
in people who are
receiving this in high
concentrations such
as IV in the hospital
or long-term use.
TMP, SMX, it's
used for a lot of
different things.
The aerobic gram,
negative infections,
and community
-acquired MRSA, it's
still susceptible.
The systems are
UTI, traveler
diarrhea and
gastroenteritis, so gut,
urinary tract, gut,
upper respiratory
tract, so acute otitis
media, and community
-acquired MRSA. So those
are the general baskets
of therapeutic uses.
Nocardia,
drug of first
choice. Neocardia is
a gram-positive
organism that can
cause some serious
infections,
especially in
immunocompromised people.
Here's listeria.
We do use
ampicillin together
with gentamicin.
So if for some
reason the patient
can't have that, then the
TMP-SMX might be
a good option.
Pneumocystis pneumonia.
So pneumocystis
urovici, it is the
drug of choice.
Whenever you see a
drug of choice, put
it under your hat
that that's something
that you need to
be remembering.
Toxoplasma gondii,
so that's the
sulfadiazine pyromesamine.
And I should put on here
also, under
some protozoa,
malaria.
which is paramethamine
and sulfidoxine.
So here are some
check-your-knowledge
questions just
running down
the line and
everything that's in
the learning
objectives. In fact,
the target, the
antibacterial
spectrum, the
resistance mechanisms,
what's intrinsically
resistant,
what is the spectrum,
that susceptible
organisms would respond.
Why do we combine
sulfonamides
with the trimethoprim?
One,
alone they are
bacteriostatic. Together
they are bactericidal
and synergistic.
I didn't mention
it before,
but it is on the slide.
What are the names
of sulfonamide
and the DHFR
inhibitor, so
sulfamethoxazole
and trimethoprim,
sulfadiazine and
pyrimethamine,
sulfadoxine and
pyrimethamine.
TMP-SMX is a drug
of choice for no
cardiosis and for
pneumocystis pneumonia.
What is the proposed
mechanism of rashes
caused by the sulfonamide
treatment? That's
related to the toxic
reactive oxygen species
that can cause direct
toxicity and also
the metabolites that
can form a haptin and
draw an immune response.
And this occurs
in people who are
poor metabolizers of N
-acetyltransferase,
type 2, and individuals
who do not have adequate
glutathione stores
to detoxify those
reactive oxygen species.
So that's the proposed
mechanism of rashes
and certain systemic
adverse effects that
are related to
hypersensitivity reactions.
the sulfonamides are
not recommended in in
fact they're contraindicated
in newborns and
young infants because
of the risk of
kernectoris because
young infants do not have
well they have immature
metabolic systems
immature blood brain
barrier what sulfonamides
are used topically
for burn treatment so
silver sulfodiazine and
mafenide and what are
two adverse effects
of mafenide acetate so
metabolic acidosis due
to carbonic anhydrase
inhibition and also
pain on application.
So in summary
this is pretty
much what we
just went through
and here are the answers.
I hope that you'll
try and answer the
questions without looking
at the answers. And
that concludes the
lecture on the folate
synthesis inhibitors.